stylish Li late to the party but never
one to be left out
Bentley introduced a luxury SUV the been
tiga now they've added another engine to
the range and we got to test it in
Austria's Tirolean Alps car tester
Emmanuelle Shaffer remembers when the
Bodega first appeared in 2016 it only
offered a choice of a gasoline powered
w12 or a diesel v8 now Bentley has added
a relatively small gasoline-powered v8
the four liter v8 with turbochargers
supply the vent again with a full 404
kilowatts of power that carries it from
0 to 100 km/h in just 4.5 seconds
topping out at 290 Bentley rates fuel
consumption at eleven point four liters
per 100 kilometers in Germany the vent
aigis starts at 174 thousand eight
hundred eleven euros a good 33 thousand
five hundred euros less than the w12
emanuelle explains that thanks to the
twin turbochargers the v8 puts out only
42 kilowatts less than the 12 cylinder
engine and even feels a bit sportier
that has less to do with the lighter
weight only 30 kilograms less than with
the sound it boasts that familiar v8
roar further enhanced by the twin quad
tailpipes at the rear in front the bin'
tiga shows the classic Bentley face the
round headlights and high matrix grille
at the same time Bentley's exploring new
heights
riding on 22 inch alloy wheels with a
polished black finish and brought up by
a pert rear the been take it strikes a
graceful figure the twin quad tailpipes
add a finishing touch the interior
offers the trademark Bentley luxury long
familiar from the car makers other
models most immediately impressive are
the hand-stitched leather trim steering
wheel and the real wood instrument panel
and center console inserts
[Music]
it's a pleasure to sit on this Bentley's
rear seat it's spacious and offers two
removable entertainment tablets with 4G
and Wi-Fi to ensure there's never a dull
moment on the road the new v8 gasoline
engine is coupled with a ZF 8-speed
automatic transmission permanent
all-wheel drive distributes the torque
in a ratio of forty to sixty front to
rear split that will get it across
rugged terrain or through snow with
little difficulty but there's even more
technology to ensure a safe trip
[Music]
dibban take Amano Elle points out that
the VIN tag is two separate electrical
systems the conventional clove volt
long standard in most vehicles which
powers the lighter socket among other
things and now a 48 volt system that
runs the electric motor for the active
role stabilization that helps keep the
car on the road if the driver takes a
curve too fast
it applies up to 1200 Newton meters to
counteract the centrifugal force and
when it's not needed for instance on
straightaways the system disconnects
itself to maximize comfort for the
driver and passengers given the choice
between the v8 gasoline engine and the
top-of-the-range w12 what exactly speaks
for the smaller unit Amanda well thinks
that aside from the greater sportiness
it would have to be the price savings in
relation to the w12 even then this is an
SUV only for the well-heeled car buyer
we go
you